now it's time to launch the settings
activity from the menu item we need to
launch it from two places the main
activity and the detail activity
afterwards compile and run the app to
make sure that it works this is what it
should look like from the main activity
if you tap on settings menu it should
bring you to the settings activity it is
expected for it to be blank because we
haven't populated it yet now let's try
the detail activity if you tap on a
forecast you can go into the detail
activity and then you can go into the
settings activity complete the task and
then verify that your app behavior is
like this in the directions I just
provided and in the following videos of
this course you'll notice that the
settings activity had an action bar at
the top of the screen when building your
app with the latest version of the
support library the action bar doesn't
show up by default in the settings
activity as a result it's expected and
correct that your device looks like this
with no action bar don't worry we'll add
the action bar back when we change the
theme of the settings activity in lesson
5 for more info check the instructor
notes